the Joe Rogan experience got in trouble
and yeah this is one of the things like
when like that parkland joke that he did
I was like that's not his best joke but
it's also he's working it out yeah
doesn't stand up in ten [ __ ] months
he's working it out but if you say that
he's different now we're getting to see
the real Louie like [ __ ] you better go
through his library yeah that's what he
did
yeah the purpose is like his ninth most
offensive joke yeah not even close he's
he's that's what he does it's called
comedy yeah the idea was like well but
we didn't know he was here know him you
assume what you believed what he fed or
you wanted to believe I actually I have
a theory that one of the reasons people
like the New York Times and and other
media outlets got brought the hammer
down so hard on him is because they'd
heard the rumors and ignored them so now
they have to signal that like this is
wrong because there were rumors before
right and they were like we don't like
they would they ignored them so now they
have to overcompensate be like he is
absolutely he's the face of hypocrisy
and evil okay well he just caught it at
the worst time ever really yeah he just
is that's a bad he had beachfront
property during a start you get the deep
stilts not the [ __ ] yeah like he had
such ones your flat my cup here's what I
want to talk about with you the idea
because whenever I tell people we're
friends or that I go on your show
they're like knocking I'm like first of
all because you're a [ __ ] good dude
and have been a good dude for 27 years
that I know of to me
thank you it doesn't mean you're always
good whatever you're always good to do
it every time I said whatever I don't
[ __ ] know your life I don't know what
you do outside of [ __ ] Encino the and
now the next question becomes why do you
have cranks on what people would
consider cranks on the show and you and
I have talked about this a little bit
off the show
explain because you are basically
liberal yes but you believe in having
hardcore right-wing people on because
you like them personally or you like you
believe it's worth some of them I like
personally so it's worth having a
conversation like ben shapiro was one
that had a long conversation with he's
one of the more controversial guys that
i'm on how people get upset at me and
call me an alt writer meanwhile he's
been attacked by the alt-right you know
i mean he wears a yarmulke for christ
sake he's not all right it's not a white
supremacist by any stretch of the
imagination he was the number one target
for anti-semitic remarks in the entire
world in 2016 well he's but we had a
in-depth conversation a very long one
about gay people yeah cuz he's I saw a
little bit of it where he was like he
kind of didn't he kind of got a little
lost
well yeah because it doesn't well he had
two different take here's like David
Parkman had an interesting take on it
Pakman said that if you look at his
explanation because I asked him a couple
things I'm like do you really believe
that Moses part of the Red Sea and he
said I would look for more naturalistic
explanation for that but then when I
talked to him about gay people and gay
things he wasn't exactly in a
naturalistic destination and he also
wasn't interested in giving people the
ability to do whatever they want he felt
like you're not you're supposed to
resist that and his take is that like
you you have an urge to murder people
but you don't do it because you're a
good person and you should do the same
thing with being gay and I was like wow
that's a crazy that's crazy mental
gymnastics so that is a natural even
natural occurring thing that God is
testing you with I mean I'm done putting
work as many I think but essentially
that's his position his position is that
God doesn't want you to do that it's in
the Bible he doesn't do it I mean he
goes hard yeah he doesn't use
electricity and the Sabbath till the Sun
Goes Down the whole deal yeah and you
know a lot of people like you know you
given this guy a platform like look I'm
communicating with someone and I like
him as a person he's a very nice guy I
don't agree with him at all about that
about the guy you believe it's worth
giving people a platform but it should
see
not platter but like I think that's a
real problem that's discussing things
like that like giving people a platform
yeah because we're living in this world
of D platform yeah people I think that's
inherently dangerous and I think that
just stopping people from their ability
to communicate just makes more pressure
on their side it makes more people that
are on the fence support them because I
see you as being a censor and that's
what I think we found out with Jack from
Twitter Jack Dorsey when he came on and
talked to me about it and when he
brought vid John who's the lawyer and
you know like sensory one is censoring
all sort of it's not smart it's it's not
good it does the opposite of what are
you intended to do it makes the other
side magnified it makes whoever you're
censoring more popular and makes them an
underdog and it also goes against core
American values like the freedom of
speech and I know that these are private
institutions and I know that they're not
necessarily forced to uphold what we
determine as free speech in terms of
like how it's written in the
Constitution in the Bill of Rights I get
I understand that but I think that the
principles of human interaction on this
planet are largely dictated by our
ability to discuss things even if you
disagree I actually do agree with you
that that the I think like deep
platforming and silencing and he's a
danger I don't there are very few people
that well there's no one that I agree
with 100% of the time right including
yourself yes including your joke about
like you don't agree with yourself like
I don't and I don't like real
yeah well that's also there's something
Buddhists about it which is like your
thoughts are not correct right they're
not even your thoughts they're just like
pendant upon your ocean sometimes yes
their dependence upon your stress levels
yeah you know sometimes you just like
your you just don't have it in you like
stop yeah other times the same situation
you'd be super calm and reasonable and
maybe you could turn it around yeah if
you've eaten yeah like that's all thing
if a doctors are worse in the afternoon
oh I'm sure judges are worse hurt search
before we get surgeries in them yeah
yeah so - you're right wait I think the
right wing thing is just an easy way to
dismiss me because I'm not right wing if
you ask me my positions on things that's
very left-wing yeah
the only thing that I
very with the orthodoxy is with the
Second Amendment with gun rights I don't
think it's that simple I know a lot of
really good people that have guns and I
know a lot of really good people that
never shoot anybody that have guns to
protect themselves yeah and to label
everyone the same is just like labeling
everyone who drives a car the same as
those in cells that drove into people in
Montreal or were that it was it was at
Toronto wherever that was
yeah it's we have a real problem
labeling people and labeling people with
it's lazy and it's an attempt to
marginalize or dismiss their positions
and it also feels good yeah to do it she
feels good to like I guess what writing
them off I'm superior I have a very
clear moral view I'm taking out one of
my moral paintbrushes Jones ooh you are
that even if it's not a moral position
even if like that Neal Brennan he's such
a left-wing cuck yeah he's a listen to
that and boom and there you go I got him
in a box I'm gonna put a ribbon on it
yep ship him off so you've read the
comments yes when I'm on the canceled
you're canceled I heard yeah
[Applause]